[Music]
when it comes to sharing their
extravagant lifestyle rich kids don't
think twice about posting every
frivolous purchase every exotic vacation
and photos of their luxury vehicles on
snapchat although it's fun to live
vicariously through their snap stories
there comes a point when their post
crossed a line from aspirational to
douchey if you're new to our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up because
today we're sharing 10 juicy posts of
the rich kids of snapchat their
unconventional utensils 1 wealthy
snapchat user posted a photo of himself
wearing a Rolex watch and buttering his
bread with his release American Express
black card the black card was introduced
in 1999 as a way to cater to the
company's wealthy clients most card
holders charge an average of 250,000 or
more per year and they have an average
net worth of 16 million dollars since
rich kid is obviously living in the lap
of luxury by using his prestigious
credit card instead of using a knife
their extravagant holidays many people
can't wait to hunt for eggs when Easter
rolled around most eggs are stuffed with
dollar bills candy and fun little toys
flat for the rich kids of snapchat their
Easter is all about lots of designer
goods this snapchatter posted a photo of
their Easter haul and it was full of
nothing but rocky a Chanel and Dior sure
spending thousands of dollars on fancy
items has nothing to do with the true
meaning of Easter but do you think these
rich kids care not a chance
showing off their money in case you
weren't sure whether or not these kids
were faking their luxury lifestyle
they've never missed an opportunity to
confirm their wealth by flashing loads
of money on snapchat this rich kid was
ready to begin his holiday and in true
gooshie fashion he snapped a picture of
himself covered in thousands of dollars
with a very smug look on his face even
though his parents probably gave him the
money that didn't stop him from showing
off in front of his snapchat followers
flaunting their material items for most
of us going to the Apple store is a big
deal we have to save up a few paychecks
to get our hands on the latest
technology but for rich kids verging on
electronic devices is no big deal they
don't even think twice about dropping
over $3,000
is on multiple iPads and of course they
have to share the photos of their new
shiny devices all lined up in a row it's
just another reminder that they're super
rich and we're not damaging expensive
items would you ever consider using your
most prized possession as a table for
both of us we'd like to protect our
expensive items to ensure they don't get
damaged but rich kids couldn't care less
about breaking a thousand dollar piece
of equipment this rich kid snapped a
photo of himself and joined some cereal
with an Apple monitor at his tabletop he
captioned the photo mom said no crumbs
on the floor so no cringing so douchey
they have too many choices life is all
about choices but for most of us our
choices are limited especially when it
comes to obtaining luxury items for the
rich kids of snapchat they are making
decisions all day long from which luxury
pair of shoes they should wear to class
to which $200,000 vehicle they should
drive to campus these are the kinds of
decisions most of us wouldn't mind
having to make showing up to class
looking fancy most students roll out of
bed and show up to class in their
comfiest sweatpants and tattered
t-shirts but you'll probably never see a
rich kid dressed down in class they're
wealthy and they want everyone to know
it at all times this rich kid to the
photo of the Rolex watch he wore to his
English class
it may seem inappropriate to wear such a
pricy timepiece to school but for rich
kids a luxury accessory is really no big
deal bragging about their transportation
to be rich means to have a fleet of
luxury cars at your disposal but for
those who are really wealthy they travel
by air this rich kid posted a photo of
his ride for the night his very own
helicopter well that's one way to beat
the traffic they practically waste money
if you had an extra $20 in your pocket
you would probably hold on to it for a
rainy day right well that's the
difference between those who live
sensibly and those who live life without
a care in the world these rich kids
treat money like it grows on trees and
why shouldn't they the moment they run
out of funds their bank accounts are
probably instantly replenished with even
more money they don't even think twice
when it comes to tossing their money in
the trashcan or using it as toilet paper
making fun of the less fortunate it's
easy to get lost in the glitzy and
lavish lifestyles of the rich kid
of snapchat but there's another side to
these spoiled rotten kids that would
make you cringe many of these rich kids
go out of their way to poke fun at the
less fortunate like this snapchat user
who photographed a friend drawing the
Chanel logo on a pair of shoes the
caption reads how scholarship kids fit
in to poke fun of the students whose
parents can't afford to bankroll their
education and their lifestyle there's
nothing wrong with these kids flaunting
their wealth and making fun of those who
have less than them is going a bit too
far don't you agree we could be douchey
snapchat posts annoyed you the most let
us know in the comment section down
below
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up
[Music]